good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
it's victory day in moscow and president
putin is preparing to address his people
ahead of the event that marks the soviet
union's defeat of nazi germany back in
world war ii
but a warning shot across the bars this
morning from the defense secretary and
an observation about what may happen to
russia if they carry on as they are in
ukraine we're live in moscow's red
square and we'll bring you the parade as
it happens plus president putin's speech
and that's around eight o'clockish
joined by the former head of british
army as well that's general lord danette
of course here in the studio to talk us
through it and we'll get the view of a
current member of russia's state duma
who's a chief critic of the russian
opposition plus those beers with clear
headlines just aren't going away we're
joined today by the shadow health
secretary wes streeting to find out what
he thinks it's monday the 9th of may
as russia's leader prepares for victory
day celebrations in moscow an
observation from the defense secretary
about what may happen if putin carries
on as he is
in ukraine there's tension over what new
plans russia may have in store as the
president here confirmed 60 killed in a
russian air strike on a school
pressure grows as secure stamina pulls
out of a keynote speech after a weekend
of headlines over beer gate claims
protocol problem we're live in belfast
as the northern ireland secretary
appeals to political parties to form an
executive after sinn fein's victory
hunger pains i'm at a community kitchen
here in harrow as new research reveals
that one in seven adults are now
struggling to eat every day
jody coma for help
killing it at the baftas jodie coma and
sean bean win big
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world from ireland to sri
lanka reveal new details about the
queen's platinum jubilee and discuss her
health with the royal commentator and
author robert jobson that's at 9 45
[Music]
tributes for dennis waterman the star of
minder and the sweeney who has died at
the age of 74.
[Music]
hello everyone a very good morning
president putin is preparing to lead
this morning's celebrations marking the
soviet union's victory over nazi germany
in world war ii troops tanks rockets and
missiles will parade through moscow's
red square and putin could give an
update on his intentions in ukraine the
defense secretary meanwhile has fired a
warning shot across the bows of russia's
leader with an observation about what
may happen to russia if they carry on as
they are in ukraine well victory days
celebrates the soviet union's role in
defeating nazi germany marking the
anniversary of the end of the second
world war the main event is a major
parade in moscow's red square to
showcase russia's military force
overseen by senior kremlin officials the
exact scale of events isn't confirmed
but russia's defense minister has said
military parades will be held in 28
russian cities involving nearly 65 000
people and 2 400 types of weapon
meantime president zolensky has accused
the russian army of replicating nazi
atrocities
russia has forgotten everything that was
important to the victors of world war ii
but ukraine and the whole free world
will remind it so that then no one will
forget so that really important words
never again which are repeated all over
the free world every year on the days of
remembrance of the victims of world war
ii regain their weight again
i am grateful to all our defenders who
are defending and saving ukraine from
the modern descendants of that old evil
well our security and defense editor
deborah haynes is standing by in kiev
for us this morning hello to you deborah
uh i wonder if we could talk about that
parade in in moscow as well as uh the
place where you are at the moment one
wonders what opportunities president
putin might take during his speech
yes well
the speech is going to sound very
different to the one that he probably
had hoped to write given that this
invasion of ukraine was meant to involve
a lightning strike on the capitol keeve
with the capital falling within days
that did not happen uh instead you had
this uh rather in in undignified russian
retreat um and then regrouping down in
the east of course president putin will
be speaking about the the special
military operation as he calls it here
today uh victory day is the most
important military day in the calendar
um of the year it's a it's a hugely
important
moment and he will want to be grasping
that moment at achieving some kind of
control over the narrative here that
things are going to plan in ukraine when
clearly they're not and the big question
of course is what he says about throwing
forward is he going to be signaling a
greater mobilization of forces in russia
to come here to fight in ukraine is he
going to start using that word war when
he talks about the operation that is
happening here and is he going to give
any further details about the ultimate
strategy what he will deem as success
these are all questions that people
don't yet know the answers to we'll be
listening very keenly to what he says
thank you
of course we are uh covering the events
in moscow for you throughout the day
today and the former head of the british
army will be with us here in the studios
to talk us through events nine o'clock
we'll be hearing from the defense
secretary who is making um a speech and
we will be taking that for you live as
well uh representing the government this
morning is the university's minister
michelle donald hello to you thank you
for joining us on the programme this
morning lots to talk about i want to
start with northern ireland though is it
a stalemate
um as a result it's hemorrhaging money
there's no working government
what's the british government going to
do
our priority of course is to deal with
the the problem head-on we have a duty
uh towards the people of northern
ireland who are a fundamental part of
the uk as you point out the northern
ireland protocol is not working
and i i believe you know the the uh
concerns about that were reflected in
the recent result that we saw in the
election we're working at pace to
resolve this nothing's off the table
okay so what are you going to do
well we are negotiating with the eu to
find a solution as we've said nothing is
off the table here if we need to um we
will through article 16 but we want to
try and negotiate as our first priority
scrapping the protocol
as i said that is that is on the table
as one of the options our first um
attempt here is to try and negotiate
with the eu we want to resolve this at
pace we want a fundamentally a
functioning executive within northern
ireland for the people of northern
ireland that is simply not possible
unless we can resolve the issues around
the protocol so you are considering
scrapping the protocol
well that's been government policy uh
for for a while now we we've said very
openly nothing is off the table our
priority here is that the people of
northern ireland resolving this problem
getting a functioning executive up and
running
okay but um we hear from our island
correspondent of the 90 people just
elected to the assembly 54 of them are
in favor of the protocol in some form so
you'll be going against the will of
those that have just been elected
well as we know the dep have said that
they won't sit as part of the executive
unless the issues around the protocol
are resolved i said that i didn't say
that we were definitely doing that i
said it was on the table as a potential
option what our our go-to to begin with
is is to negotiate with the eu and try
and resolve this problem and find a
workable solution
yeah but
as i've just made the point um
almost two-thirds of those that have
just been elected
uh want the protocol to remain in some
form
well yes that doesn't mean scrapping the
protocol finding a solution we are
negotiating with you to find a workable
solution that is our our primary
objective however should that not work
we would explore all options because our
goal here is to ensure we have a working
and functioning executive in in northern
ireland for the people of northern
ireland even if that was against the
will of those that have just been
elected
well as i've said multiple times here we
will not have a functioning executive
unless we can resolve this problem but i
think you know what we need to be doing
is negotiating trying to find a tangible
solution and and then you know we can
discuss with you whether that solution
is one that is popular or not what does
that tangible solution look like
well that that is uh what we're trying
to negotiate i can't outline the
solution at the moment because we are
working at pace with the eu to try and
negotiate that
i mean it has been an issue for some
considerable time now as we have seen so
i'm guessing there are some uh strides
that have been made forward what do they
look like
well at the moment we have not made the
progress uh that we would like obviously
because otherwise the problem would be
resolved we've invested a great deal of
time and money into the northern ireland
protocol but it isn't working in the way
that we want it to um for the people of
northern ireland we are negotiating
we're working at pace and we will be
over the coming days trying to rapidly
find a solution working with the eu
okay
if it's that urgent and you're
underlining that it is that urgent of
course we do have the queen's speech
tomorrow uh we could introduce or you
could introduce a bill to override the
northern ireland protocol couldn't you
well i'm not going to reveal what's in
uh the full queen speech tomorrow
that'll be in the green speech
are you ruling it out
i'm not going to uh reveal either way
what's in the queen's speech um that
would break all protocol what i am
saying is that our first step here is to
try and negotiate with the eu and find a
solution okay
okay but i suppose the people of
northern ireland good people of northern
ireland who will be watching you this
morning will be looking for some
guidance on this stalemate that is
costing not only the british government
but also the people of northern ireland
they've not had a government
an assembly in place for some
considerable time it looks as though the
dup won't want to work with the
sinn fein who won the most seats over
the weekend so they'll find themselves
in a position where potentially they're
going to have to have enough another
election again in six months time it's
an absolute mess you've got the queen's
speech tomorrow you could take the
opportunity to introduce a new bill that
would help out the people of northern
ireland
well i don't believe that the dup have
actually said that okay i believe the
dep have said that they wouldn't resume
their seats unless we resolve the issues
around the protocol which is what we are
going to do
and that is that's what i just said
well no i i think what you actually said
is that the dep wouldn't work with
champagne that's not what they've said
they've said that uh we have to resolve
the issues around the protocol that's
what we're trying to do work at pace and
sort this problem out for the people uh
of northern ireland i think we're in
agreement here okay we want to resolve
this problem i'm not sure we are um so
just to be clear you're saying that the
dup would be will your understand the
british government's understanding is
that the dup would be willing to work
with sinn fein as long as issues over
the northern ireland protocol were
resolved are you sure no i can't speak
for the dup of course i can't i'm a
representative from the the uh
conservative government but what i can
say is that the their clear red line
that they've been very clear on is that
they will not resume their seats unless
we resolve the protocol so that has to
be our absolute priority
okay how long do you think it's going to
take before there's some sort of
resolution
i'm not going to put an
arbitrary figure of a number of days
that would be foolish i think on my
behalf but what i will say is that we're
working at pace you know we want to get
this done as quickly as possible we want
a functioning executive in northern
ireland and we understand the extreme
urgency of this
i thought this deal was oven ready what
happened well yes it was the northern
ireland protocol is not working in the
way that we had uh intended it to do so
and we've been very open and frank about
that one
okay but is it not the fault of the
british government you know we did a
deal we signed the deal we then said
actually it's not working quite as we'd
wanted to the european union came to the
table to change it in some form we found
out that we were going to have a border
down the irish sea even though the prime
minister said that was absolutely not
going to happen and if we were given all
sorts of bits of paper just rip them up
he said and throw them in the bin and
here we are
more than a year two years after 18
months after uh when we were told we
were having an oven ready team
everything was going to be sorted the
people of northern ireland don't know
from day to day how much it's going to
cost them to live
look the level of
bureaucracy that is being placed on
northern ireland's businesses is not
acceptable
well look the protocol is not working in
the way that we had intended it to do so
um and that is why we are trying to
negotiate and find a solution you know
there's no point rehashing uh where we
were a year ago the eu is obviously not
acting in the way that we thought they
would in terms of the northern ireland
protocol and we are now rapidly trying
to find a solution to this to resolve
the issue to their then get a
functioning executive in northern
ireland uh brandon lewis the secretary
of state for northern ireland in the
british government has gone over to is
going over to northern ireland today i
know that across government this is a
priority for us how do we feel about a
border referendum
well i think let's not um
uh
overcook this one as of of yet you know
even uh champagne said it would be sort
of five years off their priority in the
election my understanding is that they
campaigned primarily on issues like cost
of living not on a referendum and over
50 percent
of votes were actually for uh the
unionist parties or parties that didn't
want constitutional change
yeah but they aren't in power and sinn
fein is so i put it to you again we
could be looking uh some way down the
track i'll give you that uh at
potentially this prime minister if he
wins the next second term in office
overseeing being the guy that oversaw
the breakup of the union
i think that's a bit speculative and as
you say a long a long way down the track
in terms of a topic for conversation
this election does not indicate that
there is a groundswell or a dramatic
change in terms of uh wanting a split
from the union from the people of
northern ireland and the votes cast
demonstrate that in fact they
demonstrate a commitment to the union uh
which is at the heart of the work of my
government's policy and we will continue
with that and try and sort out the
issues around the protocol
and protect the united kingdom yeah you
say it's not a topic of conversation but
i was in dublin over the weekend and
that was the only thing they were
talking about
there are there will always be some
people that uh that want to progress uh
with this agenda what i i think i said
was that
the votes cast do not indicate that a
majority of people
now want to see the breakup of the
united kingdom from those living in
northern ireland
let's move to your brief head teachers
have said they're anticipating large
increases in their school energy bills
adding that they've been forced to cut
spending on teaching teaching assistance
and lesson time how are you going to
help them
um well we are increasing school budgets
by next year next academic year school
budgets will have gone up by seven
percent per people there are also a
package of support out there to help
them with things like energy and uh and
pooling resources um but obviously we
know that the global fight against
inflation the global cost of living
crisis is is is going to be hard for
everybody and that's why as a government
we put in place 22 billion pounds worth
of support we are considering what else
to do
and and we are continuing to work with
schools on not just this issue but many
issues
and you feel that the amount of money
that you've increased their budget for
but for next year this year next year is
going to be enough to cover fuel costs
well of course we'll continue to monitor
the situation but we have um increased
school budgets substantially as i said
but it would be up seven percent per
people and we'll continue to monitor the
situation and work with schools uh to
assist them through this and through
many other things you know in the queen
speech as well we're also
launching a schools bill which focuses
on attendance and safeguarding and
standards and that is designed to ensure
that every child no matter where they're
born uh in england can have a fantastic
education and that's part of our
leveling up agenda okay just before i
let you go um beer with keir if he gets
fined should he step down
well that's a decision for for care uh
not for me
all my constituents are saying is um
that this this whole thing smacks of
sheer hypocrisy given the relentless
focus he has placed on what do you think
wrong party well i think this is a
decision for him he's going to have to
search his his soul after making this a
top priority over the last few months at
the expense of key issues like uh rising
cost of living etc but you know look
this is a this is a decision for him my
my takeaway is that it does smack of
sheer hypocrisy uh given because did you
mean to say take away then
well there you go yeah
that is good to see very quick
thanks very much for joining us thanks a
lot
bye
bye thank you talked a lot about
northern ireland that didn't win the
northern ireland protocol what is going
to happen next might have some reference
uh in the queen's speech
tomorrow all of that uh to come and to
discuss throughout the course of the
programme before though before all of
that let's find out exactly what we're
talking about with none other than david
blevins
in terms of the substantive business no
one's anticipating that the dup will
turn up and facilitate the election of
michelle o'neill as a nationalist first
minister by nominating a unionist deputy
first minister they may have championed
a hard brexit that resulted in the
northern ireland protocol creating that
border in the irish sea but they're now
demanding serious concessions from the
uk government on that issue before they
commit to restoring power sharing so the
northern ireland secretary brandon lewis
is likely to meet with all of the
parties to try to figure out is there a
way for the dup concerns to be addressed
adequately enough for them to return to
the devolved government but remember of
the 90 people elected to this new
assembly 54 of them are content to see
the protocol
implemented they see it as the least
worst option and that makes it very
difficult for the government to change
things because they could make it even
more difficult to see a power sharing
administration formed at stormont
between the election campaign and the
complicated kind process it's been a
busy few days for the political parties
but the work might be only just
beginning
in time looking at some of the front
pages for you this morning the telegraph
leads with uk defense secretary ben
wallace who's set to accuse mr putin of
mirrors mirroring the fascism and
tyranny of 70 years ago
the guardian goes on the cost of living
crisis reporting a survey has found more
than two million britons have missed
meals in the last month as they can't
afford it
many families are facing another energy
price shock as prices doubled for one in
four households that's on the front of
the mirror
boris johnson's planning to remove
hundreds of eu laws which he says will
boost the economy that's according to
the times
the sun pays tribute to minder and the
sweeney tough guy dennis waterman who
has died at the age of 74.
so lots of talk there about the cost of
living crisis a reminder that next week
will be taking the show on the road for
a special series of programs i'm going
back to my roots and finding out how the
good people of wigan feel about the cost
of living crisis do let me know if you'd
like to get involved by sending me a
tweet and that's going to be here on sky
news at the usual time from the 16th of
may
many of you have already got in touch
but always great to hear from you use
the hashtag at k burley and we will
reach out to you i promise now as new
research shows a dramatic rise in the
number of people struggling to buy food
will speak to a single mom worried about
the rising cost of living
as the labour leader faces more pressure
over beer gate we'll be joined by the
shadow health and social care secretary
where streeting
and then after eight the former chief of
the general staff lord richard dunnett
is with us here in the studio as russia
marks victory day
[Music]
also making news for us this morning at
least 44 people have died after their
boat capsized off the coast of western
sahara 12 people have been detained
under morocco's migration laws
authorities there say 16 bodies have
been recovered
from today face masks will no longer be
required in schools in wales school
staff and secondary school pupils have
been required to wear them when moving
around buildings and in communal areas
boris johnson has eaten fukushima
popcorn given to him by the japanese
prime minister after restrictions on the
import of produce grown near the old
nuclear plant were lifted the food
standards agency decided to scrap a
threshold that limits japanese imports
that cain contained more than 100
becquerels a measure of radioactivity
per kilogram
two palestinians have been killed in
separate incidents in the occupied west
bank hours after police apprehended two
palestinian men suspected of killing
three israelis last week
israeli soldiers shot dead a palestinian
near the barrier with the west bank and
another was killed after infiltrating a
jewish settlement inside the occupied
territory
a new report by mps says the rise of
online influencers has exposed
regulatory gaps which leave children at
risk of exploitation and says
advertising rules are being flouted
the report by the digital culture media
and sport committee called on the
government to strengthen employment and
advertising laws
mps say children parents and schools
must get be given i'm not sure what that
picture is there guys i'll let's just
work with it given more support
in developing media literacy the report
urges the government to conduct a study
into the influencer ecosystem so it can
be properly regulated we can see from
what the advertising standards authority
tells us that literally they almost have
no sort of grip at all on this sector
that they know that two-thirds of
adverts are effectively not even
designed as such or designated as such
and we know as well that there is no
protections in place for children
well new management is set to be
appointed for the convenience store
chain mccall's rival bidders morrisons
and the eu group are in a race to buy
more than a thousand stores owned by the
brand
et group owned by billionaire easter
brothers has been poised to buy mccolls
but morrison's matched its 11th hour
improved offer on sunday
tv baftas took place in london last
night featuring its first full audience
in two years jody coma picked out best
actress for her role in covid 19 drama
help and paid tribute to the care
workers who assisted in the production
of the series
biggest thank you of all goes to all of
the carers
and the dementia society who helped us
in our research and they were so
incredibly
gracious and generous with their time
channel four's it's the sin missed out
on a best miniseries to bbc drama time
starring sean bean and stephen graham
i'm not being funny but not when
everyone says we've weren't expecting
this
we weren't
on mimar's life we weren't expecting it
the skies are coming up they now
concerns over the privatisation of
broadcasters was a common theme
throughout the night
the bbc and channel 4 are things that we
have to hold tight
and fight for inch inch ink every inch
the next mo gilligan or the next judy
love or like whoever like can can watch
us and say wow that's what i want to do
do you know i mean so that's why we have
to save it
your new doctor who
and gracing the stage was also the star
of netflix sex education will be taking
over from jodi whitaker as the time lord
i'm feeling very very excited very
honored i think it's such
an honor this role is it's a british
institution and it means so much to so
many people
tributes have been coming in for dennis
waterman the veteran actor known for
shows such as minder and the sweeney
who's died at the age of 74.
[Music]
terry mccann in minder from the late 70s
running around the criminal underworld
of west london for seven series he also
performed the show's theme tune i could
be so good for you which became a hit in
the uk and also in australia remember
this
what about that part in these tenders
they've already got a scene mine's much
better
lots of things are happening in albert
square
yes
he was also the target of a caricature
on the bbc series little britain as you
saw where david williams impersonated
him as a comically small man who would
write the theme tune and sing the theme
tune for his new job offers well matt
lucas the other half of little britain
was among the first to leave tributes to
waterman tweeting
i grew up watching dennis waterman's
iconic performance in the sweeney and
minder his guest appearance in our
little britain live show at hammersmith
apollo in which he hilariously dueted
with david's absurd impersonation of him
remains the absolute highlight of my
career
a league of gentlemen actor reese
shirsmith said r.i.p dennis waterman
when i worked with him on new tricks he
made me the best cups of tea and of
course i just spent the time grilling
him about scars and dracula
quick look at the weather for you
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
southern britain will be mostly fine
today but rain will spread through the
north and south
and also the west on strengthening winds
mild but windy for many
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now this is cool an unexpected site in
kiev's underground yesterday youtube's
bono and the edge
[Music]
they performed a 40-minute concert
it's amazing
they performed alongside members of the
popular ukrainian group and lita and
tilita i think in a metro station
currently used as a bomb shelter ut
frontman tweeted that he'd been invited
to perform by president zielenski as a
show of solidarity with the ukrainian
people
uh it's the flicks in bricks the sun
provides a miniature picture game
inspired by animation morgan spencer's
lego adaptation of uh you remember we
did only fields and horses on friday
well how many of these blockbusters can
you guess
right
pretty tricky to see at them um i was
hoping they'd be a little bit bigger
maybe they will for the next hour
obviously we've got this one haven't we
matt i'm going to say that that has got
to be a james bond one hasn't it i would
have thought undoubtedly and if we go up
to the top left i'm going to say that is
dirty dancing what do you think that
looks a bit dirty dancing to me the
water thing and then
over to the right hand side that is
undoubtedly going to be titanic those
are my best guesses let me know what you
think
cool
uh a work of art the telegraph shows off
hamish maki's 11-foot sculptures which
have taken him a year to complete the
bronze hairs will be unveiled at this
year's chelsea flower show they're
pretty cool aren't they
everything's cool today and the thai's
pictures some rather fetching young men
dressed in red awaiting members of the
59 club a motorcycle association which
was founded in 1962 which is celebrating
obviously it's 60th birthday
meantime let's take you to adam parsons
should we uh he's standing by in moldova
for us uh this morning
excuse me hello to you it's good to see
you this morning talk us through the uh
the events behind you
[Music]
yeah well this is the heart of the
moldovan capital and as you can see
around us you've got gatherings of
hundreds and hundreds of people
who are going to mark victory day we
expect this to number into the thousands
now why this is very significant so a
lot of these people you can see the ones
wearing orange t-shirts are here from uh
from the communist party
and there's been a lot of
a lot of rules put in place around this
parade to stop
over displays of support for russia
despite the fact there are plenty of
people in moldova who are sympathetic to
the russian regime and one of the things
to look out for is a specific thing
that's been banned it's a ribbon called
george's ribbons and orange and black
stripes i've already seen one person
wearing them police say they will arrest
those who are wearing those ribbons they
are
assigned in a sense uh memorializing
celebrating russian military success but
what we are seeing is a lot of people
wearing combinations of orange and black
effectively a tacit sign of support
we've also
heard from the moldovan government that
they don't want to see any zeds well we
know how many times we've seen that as a
sign of russian support now you might
ask why why is moldova so central to
this story well moldova is caught in a
very tricky position it's got ukraine
all around it's north east
and south it's got romania european
union country
over to the west but
there's a region called transnistura in
the east of moldova and transnistria is
run by pro-russian separatists it's
effectively been an autonomous
self-proclaimed area ever since the
soviet uh empire collapsed transnistria
wants to get closer to russia there are
fears that putin if he drives his way
through the south of ukraine could
create a land corridor to trans history
and once use events like this to ferment
this consent and to ferment pro-russian
support
okay for now thank you adam thank you
of course we're hearing from president
putin that's about eight o'clock this
morning and then we're also hearing from
our own defense secretary and that is
around about 9 00 a.m it's called a
victory parade day in um
moscow joining us now is a guinea pop
he's an mp in russia's state duma from
president putin's party hello to sir
thank you for joining us on the
programme this morning why is the
kremlin bombing ukraine
it's not a simple question we are not
the one
we had
military infrastructure and we're doing
that for almost two months and we're not
going to attract sweden's
uh infrastructure not being attacked
sweden people and we are just fighting
nazis and neo-nazism on ukraine and now
we are on
uh
rescuer it's the last preparation for
victory parade here and we are waiting
for
uh mr putin's
speech here and
that's a wrong question which you ask me
we are not attack uh we are not bombing
ukraine we are attacking only military
infrastructure we are doing their
militarization here
so what about when
when theaters and schools are bombed and
children
are losing their lives and women are
being raped and then murdered are you
suggesting that they're neo-nazis as
well
you know it's just huge hypocrisy that
you asking me
this question just now we are at war
with ukraine nazis
about eight years and ukrainian
artillery was shelling ukrainians and
donbass schools
hospitals
kindergartens for eight years almost 14
000 people already killed by ukrainian
army but you asking me about uh killed
the children just now just after eight
years of war in donbass of course the
ukrainian army are using uh civilians as
a life shield it's like terrorist tactic
and of course we should fight them
so you're suggesting
that the ukrainian military
are using children as human shields and
that's why you're killing them
we are not killing children we are
trying to save children and you can see
it in mario because all civilians
all didn't
escape uh mariupol uh
still planned and now
we can see how azov batala have used
civilians
women
children
old people
as a life shield because
they didn't do they
them a permission to go
they use them as a shield
all
the walls have seen that
the theater in mario paul were a
thousand children and women were hiding
in the basement they'd put in huge
letters in front of the theater children
in white letters and it still took a
direct hit
up to 600 people died what sort of
special operation is it that means that
that's acceptable
uh would you give me just one proof that
6
600 people have killed in mariupol
sierra i didn't see
any proof of that
it's just uh ukrainian
propaganda of course civilians are dying
during this conflict and many civilians
we know that it's a huge tragedy but
uh
russian
army just attacked only
military infrastructure and we seen it
every given day
only military infrastructure if
ukrainian army ukrainian neo-nazi
italian
didn't use uh
civilians as a live shield
we
will
not to see
any civilian casualties or we will see
less civilian casualties it's they use
just the isis tactics you can see
unfortunately
so
if you don't accept that 600 people at
least 600 people died in the theater in
mariopol what do you think happened
uh i don't know exactly i haven't seen
any proof any proof and you didn't see
any proof that 600 civilians have died
on marijuana sierra i i have seen i have
seen that
some civilians have covered in some in
in mario sierra's basements but
as i know
many of them are safe right now many of
them i escaped this
this basement and
then they were evacuated to to russia
to russian shelters
what about the bombing of a maternity
hospital
where um
we saw uh people were being stretched
out and we were told that they
at least one of them was an actress and
it was fake blood do you is that what is
that your view
uh you know uh we can see that ukrainian
army used uh a lot of civilian
infrastructure as a like
as a base
they
fight from
hospitals they fight from kindergartens
they fight from schools
that's why uh we can
we we can't understand exactly where
civilians is or where and where uh uh
the military is uh because uh ukrainian
army
used a lot civilian infrastructure as a
military base as a military bases
that's why that that's why you can uh
you can
you should get a real proof
of what
was happened with
a marijuana maternity hospital because
we just we have seen an actress an
actress and we have seen her alive in
months after that we can we we have seen
all of us we have seen here alive
what does
victory in ukraine look like to you
you know it's a difficult question
because uh
we have to see
a country near us on our border which is
not uh
will be a direct threat to russia to
russian people to russian future that's
it because if you put new nato missiles
on ukrainian territory it's gonna be
directly
to russia to russian people and we just
trying to
fight with this
exact threat
what would you like to say
to the people of finland whose
government wants to join nato
they can do whatever they want
this is uh
independent territory and this is a
marine country they
our neighbors but they're not gonna
they're not gonna put uh
nuclear missiles on uh finland's
territory believe me because you will
not see
not a nuclear
baltic baltic after that
it's going to be a
new
huge threat to the peace
if
finland will
join nato and to put nuclear missiles or
some uh other nato missiles on finland's
territory i don't believe they're gonna
do that
but it's a sovereign nation it's not
it's up to them of course of course it's
up to them but
you can do whatever you want if you are
not threatening to your neighbor don't
threaten your neighbors don't bully your
neighbor
live in peace with your neighbors and
everything would be good i'm so sorry
she's doing with ukraine
yeah it's not what russia is doing with
ukraine at the moment
we are defend our territory we are
defending our country we are defending
our future from nato which is following
our
our borders and
nato is a direct threat for russian
people it's a simple matter you
have to understand
what's your advice to um
western countries other countries
who
are
is he still there
august is gone there we are diana is
standing by for us in uh moscow um hello
um diana listening to a supporter of
president putin represent putin a
representative of the duma um they're
defending the situation in ukraine
yes well that's invariably what he's
going to do he's also the presenter of
60 minutes which is a daily
three times a day talk show which is
sort of one of the main pieces of
propaganda really that you'll see on
russian state tv about uh what russia
still insists on calling this special
military operation so of course he's
going to defend it and you'll find very
few people in this country who will
speak publicly against it that's why
it's surprising that we still do manage
uh to report voices that essentially
dissent from what's going on here but
you're not going to find many of these
here today on the stands in red square
which i am looking at we've just arrived
and the parade is due to begin
pretty soon um and we await to see what
kind of a victory it is that vladimir
putin chooses to declare my sense is
that he won't declare any victory now um
that it is more the idea that victory is
on its way and he will draw
parallels between the um soviets defeat
of nazi germany their victory over nazi
germany in 1945 in what russia calls the
great patriotic war um and say that
victory will be ours in this scenario
also also drawing on the fact that uh
the soviets then were fighting nazis
which of course is the justification or
in part one of the many justifications
that vladimir putin has used for this um
offensive in ukraine to to justify going
in again that essentially they are
fighting the same goal um so i don't
think he's going to declare a wider war
but we shall have to see it won't be a
long speech but it will be a key one
okay for now thank you
as i said hearing from president putin
around about eight o'clock meantime
shadow health secretary is with us now
we're streeting good morning good
morning
talk to me about why first of all uh
your leader has pulled out of uh a
speech at the institute for government
today no idea i didn't check for coming
on so i thought it's such a trivial
thing um but the idea that as i've
obviously done a couple of these
interviews this morning the idea that
keira has been avoiding scrutiny when
he's been out all weekend in front of
cameras celebrating those brilliant
results we got in the local elections
last week um you know it's
like whether or not he's done an event
his diary changed all the time he's kind
of neither here nor there really
wouldn't it have been a perfect
opportunity for him to clear the air
with journalists and everyone else that
wanted to hear what happened in april of
last year well he's been doing that all
weekend he's been doing it consistently
uh since
he was first asked questions about
durham and let's just remember this
central fact which is the police have
looked at this before they found no case
to answer no action was taken there's no
reason to think this time round will be
any different but what it will show
is the stark contrast between boris
johnson who was fined boris johnson who
lied about there being any events
whatsoever under his own roof
boris johnson who said all of that
despite the fact we now know that
officials were wheeling in suitcases
full of booze into number ten there is
there is no comparison whatsoever
between perfectly legitimate campaigning
activity which kier has never denied
and the actions of boris johnson the
people who work for him which was rule
breaking lying completely unacceptable
and the fact that boris johnson is still
there i think is remarkable and
depressing and if conservative mps last
time i was on your program i said
conservative mps have got to do the
right thing hold boris johnson to
account well they failed to do that but
maybe last week's results in the local
election campaign and the loss of
hundreds of conservative councillors
might concentrate their minds so that if
tory mps aren't going to do the right
thing for the right reasons maybe
they'll do the right thing out of
self-preservation meantime back to what
your boss was up to um he told us um at
the time and subsequently that it was a
spontaneous curry from this document
that we've seen that was leaked by a
whistleblower who was obviously very
upset by him um and the actions of the
party it wasn't a spontaneous curry it
was planned i think we've got this we
were told that angela rayna was not
there she was there uh and we were told
for months that she wasn't there she was
there she was quite obviously there her
name was on the list we were told that
um he returned to work afterwards it
looks from the briefing notes that that
would suggest otherwise and we were told
that um 15 people were there and one has
to ask why was that reasonably necessary
what were two things one is um it was a
genuine cock-up a genuine mistake to say
that angela rainer wasn't there but
let's just look at this
but it was a genuine mistake and let's
just bear in mind there would be nothing
to gain whatsoever for saying that
kierstarma was at this event and angela
rainer wasn't not least because no rules
were broken this is perfectly legitimate
and as for this i mean one of the things
i thought was remarkable and you know i
mean credit to the male's imagination
they've managed to turn a perfectly
normal
ops note for a visit to um during an
election into some kind of great
revelation what do they think people
happen that we go on visits and just
wander around the town like in the hope
we might just do something useful we
were told it was spontaneous the food
it's there it's on the ops note take
away from spice laundry
i mean he couldn't get food from
anywhere else he went to the hotel there
was food available i am i am i am you
know breaking news kierstarma has dinner
kierstarma needs to eat dinner of course
he of course they've arranged dinner and
you know i'm not surprised that
i'm not surprised that it's there you
told us that that angela rainer wasn't
there all of this was planned you know
as with all things it's never the
cock-up it's always the cover-up but
hang on a second are we seriously saying
that we believe that kirsten and his
team have planned an event and planned a
meal in there which they knew to be
breaking the rules
i think this is ridiculous that
kierstama is someone who practices what
he preaches he's honest
and it's perfectly reasonable to have a
dinner this is perfectly permissible
within the rules and i've got no doubt
that after the dinner he went back to
work because anyone who's ever worked on
an election campaign knows that you work
late into the evening and i know from
working with kierstarma he works late in
the evening all the time and and i just
i mean
the police but the police or the police
will look looking forward to draw their
conclusions
i don't think people out there in the
country think that kierstarma is the
kind of bloke who goes around breaking
the rules and getting smashed on an
election campaign breaking the rules i
mean this is why i just think this is
all stretching the boundaries of
credibility and i'm frustrated because
all this is about is trying to let me
get a word in edgewood if it was
permissible uh why didn't he say why did
he not agree why did he not tell us
about all of this to start with instead
of coming up with some [ __ ] and bull
story but i don't i don't think that's i
don't think that's a fair
characterization but it was a pretty
impromptu i think that's fair uh and he
prompted you curry because he couldn't
get food anywhere else we know that
that's not true we were told that uh
angela arena was not there we can see
that wasn't true so it was in the angel
arena case it was a genuine mistake and
the late party held its hands up and
said look we're really sorry correctly
straight away rather than monkey wrong
well you know obviously someone didn't
check at the time and that was stupid
and the labour party apologized and held
our hands up and i think that's the
right way to behave and that that is a
stark contrast by the way with boris
johnson who lied regularly and
repeatedly denied there were any events
in number 10 whatsoever any rule
breaking whatsoever and then we found
out not only were rules broken under his
own roof he was there and he was
breaking the rules so look the police
are looking at this now i don't think
they'll draw any different conclusions
the one they did before but they are
looking at it and i think in the end
kiersten will be vindicated and people
will end up looking very silly so
when the prime minister was under
investigation kia stammer
said that his position was untenable
this is when he was under investigation
not about when he was actually found
himself in a position where he had
broken the rules he said honesty and
decency matter after months of denials
the prime minister is now under criminal
investigation which uh key stamina is
for breaking his own lockdown laws he
needs to do the direct the decent thing
and resign that's what he said in a
tweet and that was in january of this
year's so this was for being under
investigation not for actually
breaking
kei was absolutely right and and the
reason why boris johnson should have
resigned then was because because even
before even before no no hang on a
second even before the police drew their
conclusions and issued a fine we already
knew that boris johnson had lied to
parliament because we already knew that
parties had taken place so boris johnson
had already been caught lying to
parliament i'm under the ministerial
quote no he looked clear
yeah he's drawing he's drawing attention
to the fact that prime minister is under
criminal investigation but that but you
know he he was already calling for the
resignation anyway because because
foreign investigation your leaders also
under in criminal investigation honesty
and decency matter so if it was good
enough for the prime minister it's good
enough for him and the police have
looked at kier's case before and i've no
doubt that they will reach the same
conclusion this time and he's under
criminal investigation honesty and
decency matter they they do honesty and
decency do matter and i think their
qualities that kierstarma epitomizes i
believe he's told the truth the way
through i believe he's followed the
rules at all time and i believe that
when the police look at this again as
they are we'll cooperate fully i think
they're going to draw the same
conclusion and that will that will
strengthen the contrast between honesty
and decency after months of denial as
the prime minister is now under criminal
investigations people read that same
tweet i'll give you a different answer
look i can't what you said saying that
having not broken the rules kia stammer
should resign while the bloke in number
10 he broke the rules lied about it
still there come on he's saying that one
rule for
back at the time in you know january
2022 we already knew that boris johnson
had been caught banged to right lying to
parliament we were already
on that basis you know calling for boris
johnson to go so i don't i don't accept
that because the police are now looking
at this again
having had
you know weeks and weeks of the
conservatives and others calling for
them to do so i don't believe that
kierstama should be handing in his
resignation because the police are
looking at it the police looked at it
before there's no reason to think
they'll reach a different conclusion
this time what i do think is remarkable
is that the leader who did break the
rules who did lie who did mislead
parliament who did pretend nothing was
going on who did take the people for
fools and who did allow his officials to
wheel in suitcases for the booze is
still there can you accept at least that
this has not aged well
no i think it's perfectly reasonable
thing to say i'll stand by every single
word that keir said back then okay let
me put it this way then if
given that uh durham police are now
reinvestigating your leader should they
also be reinvestigating what happened
with dominic cummings well why not but
look i'm not going to tell the police
what to do in terms of operational
policing decisions i don't think it's
appropriate for senior politicians you
are because you're saying that they
won't find a case that rather than
waiting to see what they say no i'm
saying what i think will happen i'm not
saying police you must not find there's
a case to answer i'm saying i have
confidence on the basis of what i know
and on the basis of the man that i know
in kierstama his honesty his decency and
integrity i think the police will reach
the same conclusion they did last time
but as i've as i've always said about
the police they need to pursue um things
without fear or favor and i'm sure
that's what they'll do and i make no
criticism for them what if he gets a
fixed penalty notice i don't think he
will and i'm not even going to entertain
the prospect we'll have weeks and weeks
of the tourist slinging mud at kierstama
hoping that people will just conclude
that we're all the same there's no point
in changing prime ministers because the
next one would be as bad as the current
one and that's just not true and i'm not
going to get into the game that the
tories are playing with their friends in
the media
of trying to smear a decent man and
pretend that kierstarm's behavior is in
any way comparable with boris johnson
and how conservatives have the bare face
cheek to come out you know gloating and
demanding resignations and throwing
around accusations of hypocrisy a decent
man like kirsten i don't know they
should get their own house in order if
not for decency and honesty and public
life but for those hundreds of
conservative councillors who lost their
seats because they're prime ministers a
liar okay um you're not gonna answer
this either but i'm gonna ask you um why
are they just the one i will answer well
let's see if you will you may you may
you know you were always surprised
um do you want to be next leader
we've got a list of all of the ones
that might i'm sure that by the time
there is a leadership election i'll be
too old and people will be looking to a
new generation because after three terms
of kirsten being the prime minister of
our country people would be looking so
you don't fancy being prime minister or
a leader of the no i'm i'm i'm i'm not
any security i'm slogging my guts out to
make sure that kirsten was the next
prime minister and on the basis of the
election results we got last week a
remarkable turnaround from where labour
was two years ago i think we've got
everything to play for the next general
election and i think when people look at
kierstarma look at the values he holds
looks at the answers that we have to the
country on things like the cost of
living crisis the two million people
that we now know are cutting back on
food can't afford to eat a labor
government will deliver the alternative
our country needs and that government
will be led by kirsten okay well that's
the topic that we're going on to next
it's great to see you thank you thank
you indeed thanks for joining us joined
now by melanie lock actually she's a
single mom she's on universal credit and
she's had to already make difficult
decisions because of rising energy
prices hi thanks for joining us on the
program tell me about a normal day for
you what do you have what can you do and
what can't you do given your limited
budget
good morning kay um yes so
excuse me
on my limited budget um things that i
can't do are
um having any luxuries really um it's a
matter of living hand to mouth it's
having to budget for absolutely
everything down to the last degree of um
what my son can do in terms of
activities
there's never enough money to to cover
the basics and the necessities this is
something that i've seen i've been a
single mum now for 12 years and it's got
worse and worse and worse
um
even with government saying that they're
going to reduce 5p with the p 5p a litre
of petrol
where i haven't seen any benefit to that
um with the every time that some money
um comes to me i.e i had um a pay rise
of 1.75
like most public sector workers on low
incomes
that came in one fail hit
from a year ago
and it came to about 200 pounds that i
got in an increase in pay now that i
received last month and thought yeah i
can have something nice like a haircut
a treat for myself for the hard work
that i've done over the year to find
that this month that 200 pounds has been
automatically taken from my universal
credit so i'm at a deficit now this
month
um by that 200 pounds which obviously i
wasn't expecting like most when you get
a pay rise it's a nice little bonus to
treat yourself and your family with
unfortunately i've now got to try and
find that 200 pounds out of food
out of petrol out of my gas and
electricity bill which is just something
i can't do and this has a total effect
on my mental health and well-being
because i'm constantly stressed and
wondering where i can get this other
money from i've borrowed the max i can
from everybody up until this point
because nothing actually supports
me when the money's not there i mean
government's attitude tends to be
yeah we really appreciate you taking the
time to explain all of that to us good
luck and and thank you very much indeed
for joining us do stay in touch let us
know if there's anything we can do
thank you thank you